si allah proche du 11 mai disons jeudi 7
mai il apparaissait que le nombre de
nouveaux cas journalier n'était pas dans
la fourchette prévue que nous ne
parvenions pas à casser les trop
nombreuses chaînes de contamination
alors nous devrions en tirer les
conséquences
je le dis aux français si les
indicateurs ne sont pas au rendez vous
nous ne déconfit non pas le 11 mai où
nous le ferons plus strictement je
préférerai croyez moi que les
modélisateurs les épidémiologistes
puisse nous dire que leurs hypothèses de
3000 cas par jour 11 mai se vérifie mais
si tel n'est pas le cas je le dirai avec
autant de clarté qu'il faudra hier j'ai
reçu du directeur général de la santé
des modélisations moins favorable
peut-être parce que les comportements se
relâche un peu peut-être parce que la
baisse des hospitalisations est trop
lente
peut-être aussi parce que les hypothèses
sur lesquelles sont fondées ces
modélisations ne vont pas s'avérer exact
je le dis ici devant la représentation
nationale avec solennité
ces incertitudes doivent inciter à tous
les français pardon tous les français à
la plus grande discipline d'ici au 11
mai et à lutter contre les risques de
relâchement que nous sentons parfois
monter dans le pays